This little pocket pistol, will shoot a matchstick
with power, blast toothpicks into fruit, and
lob fiery darts over 20 feet away.
In this project we're turning your boring
old clothes pins, into a powerful arsenal,
of desktop weaponry.
All we need for this project, is some wood
glue, a utility knife, and a simple clothespin.
Just make sure it's the wooden kind with the
metal spring.
Alright, let's get started by pushing on the
clothespin sideways, so we can break the tension,
and remove the spring.
Next we'll need to hold the two wooden pieces,
back to back, so the notches line up near
the center, like this.
Now let's make a marking on the top piece
about half an inch from the hole, and an angled
marking on the bottom, that we'll cut out
later.
Now just for convenience, I've gone ahead
and filled in all the areas that will need
to be chiseled out, so grab your utility knife
and carefully carve out all the areas marked
in blue.
The long channel we just made here, is going
to be one half of our gun barrel.
Let's go ahead and carve the other half, into
the bottom piece as well, then cut out a notch,
where we made that other mark earlier.
With our two pieces cut and pressed together,
you should have something that looks like
this.
Ok, it's time to make this permanent, so why
don't we try using a dab of wood glue on a
scrap piece of paper, then carefully slide
the pieces through it, giving them both an
even coating.
Now simply press the two sides together, wiping
away any excess glue, and let it sit for a
bit.
After about 5 to 10 minutes it should be just
strong enough for us to attach the spring.
Push one end of the spring, into the inner
chamber, and hook the other end over the outside
notch.
With the spring in place, your pocket gun
is finished and ready for action.
All we need now are some wooden matchsticks,
that we can use as ammunition, and they should
slide loosely into the barrel.
You can see that as we continue pushing the
match, the gun cocks itself automatically,
and is instantly ready to fire.
You can hold it just like a little pistol,
and when you're ready to shoot, simply pull
the trigger.
It's amazing to see, just how much power is
stored in the spring.
That's evident by how it slams forward in
just a fraction of a second, blasting our
projectile over 20 feet away.
Now let's see if this can work with toothpicks
as well.
If we snap off one of the sharp ends, it exposes
a broader surface, which just might work.
Why don't we go ahead and test it out on an
apple.
You can see that from a distance of about
6 inches, there's just enough power to impale
the surface.
Of course, the closer you are, the deeper
it penetrates.
And it's impressive to see the results, are
all fairly consistent.
Now I went ahead a put together a whole battery
of these tabletop toys, and experimented with
different ways to handle and fire them.
I discovered a technique for lighting the
matches first, then lobbing the fiery darts
high into the air.
Which, of course, should only be done outdoors,
and with adult supervision.
Now, as a final thought, if the tip of your
gun looks like this, feel free to customize
it so it looks a little cleaner.
Another option is to carve the end back, and
smooth out the barrel with a drill bit.
Well now you know how to take any ordinary
clothespin, and turn it into a mini weapon
of mass satisfaction.
If you liked this project, perhaps you'll
like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com